If you've ever moved out of an apartment
or house, chances are you've encountered
one of these boxes.
It's not surprising since Home Depot
has the largest market share
for moving boxes, selling 75
million of them each year.
Home Depot boxes are made
exclusively by Pratt Industries
at five different paper mills in the US.
What may surprise you is
that the whole process
begins at your front steps.
First, recycled paper gets
picked up from the city curbs
and brought to the
Staten Island paper mill
by barge or truck.
John: One thing that is very
significant about our business
overall is that we only make things
out of recycled material,
we don't make anything
at all out of virgin trees.
Narrator: Then there are six main steps
in turning recycled material
into a corrugated box.
So once the recyclable
paper has been unloaded,
a large crane then comes down and lifts it
and puts it up into the pulper.
The easiest way to explain this
is if you think about a
regular washing machine
where you have an agitator in the middle,
we put the recyclable paper in there,
and then it's agitated
along with warm water
to separate the fibers out.
Narrator: Once the paper is broken down
into pulp, it goes through several
screening-and-filtering processes
to remove impurities such as
ink, plastic, rubber, and styrofoam.
What's left is a very
clean, raw paper fiber.
The raw paper fiber is
then pressed and vacuumed
into paper and then turned
into a 35-ton paper roll.
Three separate rolls of
paper are run through
a corrugating machine to create
a corrugated board.
There are two outsides and a wavy center.
The fluted middle is what gives the boxes
their crush resistence
and stacking strength.
The corrugated sheet is then cut
into three different widths depending on
the size of the box,
and each box is stamped with
Home Depot's iconic logo.
Lastly, the box is glued and shipped off
to be folded into a finished box.
John: Arguably one of
the most common things
that's just so in the background,
no one ever pays any attention to it,
but there's almost nothing that doesn't
arrive at your store or your door
one way or the other in some
kind of corrugated box, and so
you know, if you think about purely
with the rise of e-commerce, it's just
becoming more and more common,
and so it's great to be able to do
something productive with that
and turn it back into a usable product.
Our program through the Home Depot
saves about 1.4 million trees a year
and then 570 million
gallons of fresh water.
The recycle process uses
one-third of the amount of water
that a regular process would use.